你總是手腳冷冷嗎
小心喔
有一種手腳冰冷最危險
那就是
可能血流就是被卡住了
甚至是中風
或者是心肌梗塞的前兆
你常常敲「十宣穴」
血液流通
順順的時候呢
雙手就會暖暖的
它又有降血壓
預防頭暈的效果喔
胡乃文開講囉
我是你的老朋友 胡醫師
冬天時你總是手腳都會冷冷的
小心喔
有一種手腳冰冷最危險
就是單側的手
單側的腳冰冷
當你發現手或腳
只有一邊持續冰冷
麻麻的沒力氣
可不能疏忽
可能就是血流被卡住了
甚至於是中風或
心肌梗塞的前兆
不要拖 趕緊去找醫生
給你檢查吧
尤其這三種人更要小心
超過50歲的
有糖尿病的
有心血管疾病的
手腳老是冰冷
可能是血液循環出問題
長期下來
也會引發
手腳麻木
傷口難癒合
甚至於
中風或者是
心肌梗塞
手腳冰冷原來這麼嚴重
我都不知道
手腳冰冷是什麼原因
手腳冰冷是什麼體質
有這兩個原因
第一個是體質偏寒
就是你一吹到風
就覺得
寒冷喔
第二個就是血量不足或貧血
中醫稱之為血虛
就是臉色蒼白
四肢都會冷冰冰的
手腳冰冷怎麼改善呢
馬上跟你說
早晚敲敲手30下
暖手腳降血壓
手腳冷冰冰的時候
除了把手伸到
另外一半的口袋裡去
我教你有一個
不求人又有效的方法
那就是敲十宣穴
你常常敲十宣穴
血液流通順順的時候
雙手就會暖暖的
它又有
降血壓 預防頭暈的效果
十宣穴在哪裡呢
在手指尖
就是十個手指的尖端的前方
叫做十宣穴
這些地方離心臟最遠
血液循環
最容易卡卡的
我知道我知道
是不是這樣敲
對 我美麗的太太就是這樣
她每天都在那敲敲敲
自己在家裡都可以這樣敲
把你的雙手 手心相對
手指彎曲
左手和右手的指尖就這樣子
咚咚咚咚
敲它個30次
分早上晚上
各敲大概15下也就夠了
還不需要敲很多
還有一種敲法
就是讓血液循環更快的加速
就是和你的另一半
和你的美麗的太太敲起來
就這樣子敲
就這樣敲
OK
剛才手都冰冰的
現在敲一敲
我的手都溫暖了
那很讚啊
十宣穴它是
十個指頭氣血交會的地方
能幫助你通調陰陽開竅
能夠醒神
臨床上
我會用十宣穴急救
中風的昏迷的人
幫助血液重新分布
我曾經就有過一個病人
我在醫院裡頭看這個病人
另外一床的病人竟然的
中風的現象出現了
他的太太叫我說
你能不能來看一看
我一看中風
馬上在這個地方
放了一點血
立刻恢復了
3個部位不能受寒
敲腿1處去寒防掉髮
天冷了
有伴的人
最幸福的是莫過於
有人幫你蓋被子
沒伴的人
我們也要把自己
穿得夠
穿得暖暖的
多愛自己一點
人家有男友力
我有保暖力
明明穿很多
為什麼身體一直覺得冷
你檢查一下這三個地方
有沒有包得緊緊的
第一腳底
第二頸部
第三腹部
腳底是第一個要保暖好的部位
喜歡穿短襪短裙
愛露美腿的小姐
你知道嗎
我們的雙腳
是全身陽氣的發源地
腿把它裸露出來
寒風直接吹進身體裡頭
陽氣迅速的散失
這個時候
會發生什麼問題呢
寒邪就從腳
就從腿入侵了
導致手腳冰冷
血液循環差
還可能引發
關節疼痛
關節痠痛
年輕的時候為了愛美
年老的時候出現關節痛
可不划算囉
你還是選一條保暖的褲子
襪子呢選一雙厚襪子
讓腳踝到小腿的地方
都能夠保暖 留住陽氣
我待會還會教你
如何拍腎經
第二個是頸部
脖子有個風池穴 風府穴
這幾個地方呢
那個風最容易從這個地方進去
於是呢一進去了
那個風那個寒
血壓馬上往上飆高
你可以圍一條圍巾
來擋住風寒
第三是腹部
天氣太冷
你知道嗎
交感神經就會影響到腸胃
造成蠕動發生問題
讓你容易瀉肚子
女生呢很容易經痛
我們出門的時候
這樣的時候
就要把脖子
圍巾圍好
肚子就要給它
不要露出來
不要讓人看到
不是不要看
襪子也要穿得厚
沒錯我教你一個
腳底暖起來的方法
就是拍腎經
它能夠改善循環
身體暖起來
還能夠防止掉髮哦
腎經就是在腳踝的附近
這個地方呢
有三個穴位非常重要
復溜穴 照海穴 太溪穴
怎麼敲呢
你把手握成一個拳頭
從復溜穴由上往下
這樣敲到照海穴
然後呢
再從下往上
敲到太溪穴上來
敲敲敲就這樣子敲一敲
一天來回它個
三五次就可以了
來先找到復溜穴
它在小腿的內側
內踝尖上兩寸
腳那個跟腱的前方一點點
復溜穴能夠通經活絡 消水腫
關節不好
容易水腫的人
都可以常常在這裡
按一按敲一敲
再找到太溪穴
太溪穴呢
是在內踝的後方
一個凹陷的地方
它是補腎的重要的穴道哦
腎經的原動力都在這個地方
你會手腳冰冷
腰膝痠軟的人啊
都常常敲一敲太溪穴
可以保護這個腎
最後照海穴
照海穴呢
它在內踝的下方
前面一點點凹陷之處
敲它能夠改善健忘
失眠 頭髮乾燥
還能讓你不那麼怕冷
那什麼時間敲效果最好呢
在腎經最旺的時候
最旺的時候是
下午五點到七點
下午五點到七點哦
還有七點到九點的時候
也可以再來補一下啦
那上班的人
中午的時間敲一敲
這樣可以嗎
當然可以啊
為什麼不行呢
就是我講台語
就是說
有拍到就有保佑啦
不是保佑啦
那就是
有拍到就有保佑嘛
有敲到就有保佑嘛
穿厚襪腳底還是冷
1張紙腳快速升溫
怕冷的人他都穿羊毛襪
腳又冷冷的
晚上又睡不著怎麼辦
那如何讓腳底變暖
我跟你說
有一個方法很省錢
你只要把一張紙
放在鞋子裡面
就能夠讓腳底變溫暖囉
什麼紙這麼厲害啊
就是鋁箔紙
蛤 鋁箔紙可以保暖嗎
可以
你拿一張鋁箔紙
把亮面朝上
包覆住腳掌的前端
再穿拖鞋
腳底就能夠瞬間升溫
據說穿鞋子的時候
能升溫到
8度
為什麼
因為鋁箔紙的亮面
導熱效果非常的好
能把你的腳跟溫暖
迅速傳到腳趾上面去
這是一個日本自然療法的名醫
叫川嶋朗他的實驗
他是專門研究怕冷體質的醫學博士
今晚睡前你就可以試一試
你還有其他的保暖妙招嗎
留言給我們分享
大家來互相取暖
5種發熱食物
手腳暖翻天
手腳冰冷要吃什麼來改善呢
我們前面提到了
血虛型的手腳冰冷的人
你可以吃五種食物
羊肉 紅棗 肉桂 薑 韭菜
來我教你怎麼吃
我們先說羊肉
最棒的吃法就是煮成
我知道
當歸生薑羊肉湯
對不對
當然對了
答案非常肯定
你煮給爸爸媽媽先生小孩
各來一碗
吃羊肉能夠補肌肉的氣
當歸補血 生薑活血
吃完身體就暖呼呼的
促進血液循環
你自己也要記得來一碗哦
全家一起增強免疫能力
讓臉頰的氣血都紅通通的
當歸生薑羊肉湯
藥食兩用皆宜
堪稱藥物之精
醫方之祖
你有這種經驗嗎
冬天的時候
因為寒風吹到肚子裡頭
結果導致肚子劇烈的疼痛
我們中醫界有一個神級的人物
叫做張仲景
被稱之為醫聖
他用當歸生薑羊肉湯
讓這種問題的人服用
結果你知道怎麼樣了
病人只吃兩次
肚子就不痛了
身體也溫暖了
效果是很讚哦
第二個就是紅棗
月經量少
手腳冰冷
容易累的妹妹們
可以喝什麼
你可以泡一杯
紅棗薑茶
或紅棗桂圓茶
紅棗能夠補血又補氣
它會讓你那種
虛的發冷的寒氣
慢慢的就散掉了
氣血循環變得順暢
第三是薑
你炒菜煮湯等等的時候
放一點薑就很好
薑能活血散寒
外食也可以點一個咖哩飯來吃
咖哩裡面還有薑黃
能夠暖身又能夠抗發炎
第四個是肉桂
肉桂很厲害哦
它很厲害的功效是什麼呢
就是引腎氣歸於元
也就是歸到腎裡面去了
是什麼意思呢
就是保護腎氣 不會外散
增強全身的暖意
寒性體質的人
吃了手腳就暖
第五個是韭菜
有一句話說一月蔥 二月韭
在農曆二月的時候
吃韭菜最能補腎
把陽氣一路帶到手腳
改善冰冷的體質
好 我等一下要去菜市場
把這些菜都買回來